hey welcome welcome into another edition
of Market takes we are here on one of
the best days of the month and always
one of the best days of the year it's
fed day uh the first fed meeting the
first fomc meeting of 2023 I know you
could have been anywhere in the world
but you're here with me I am Dion rabone
reporter for the Wall Street Journal
this is Market takes thanks so much for
being with us we are diving all the way
into today's fomc meeting fed share
Jerome Powell's press conference uh the
FED statement we're going to get into
all of that so sit right there stick
with us we're going to get through
everything in about 15 minutes we're
going to talk through the Fed rate
decision how it aligned with
expectations of course the reactions to
it from the markets we're going to talk
about the environment coming into the
meeting today and why maybe the market
reacted the way it did why investors saw
what Fed chair Powell said and what the
rest of the fomc said the way they did
of course we're going to break down have
a very thorough breakdown of the
Chairman's press conference and also
check the markets see what stocks bonds
crypto Commodities uh currencies what
they're all doing and how they reacted
to this uh this meeting the first of the
year and talk about the outlook for 2023
and what comes next so we are going to
be doing all that uh right here on
Market takes this was quite a meeting
quite a a meeting you know really the
federally raised rates by 25 basis
points that has slowed down a Slowdown
from December when they raise by 50
basis points their previous meeting they
had raised by 75 basis points in fact
the previous four meetings prior to
December they had raised by 75 basis
points so you see we are slowing down on
the pace and Fed chair pal came out you
know he looked like he was ready to go
ready to to fight the markets he said a
lot of strong words but the market kind
of gave him the old we don't believe you
you need more people we're going to get
into what he said and why the market
reacted but look first let's talk about
the statement there were a few
differences in the FED statement from
the previous uh meeting in December to
this meeting most particularly they took
out references to the Russian war in
Ukraine or Russia's war against Ukraine
I think is how they phrased it uh saying
that that was driving prices up that
reference was removed I think the market
got a little excited by that also
changed a little bit of the wording in
terms of their outlook for the pace of
rates staying staying high as opposed to
raising and going forward that might
have gotten the market excited as well
um but again
when we talk about the Powell press
conference when when which is when the
market really took off and got excited
when you see stocks move way up when you
see bond yields move way down that was
all during the press conference and it
really kind of went against the message
that Fed chair Jerome Powell tried to
send or seem to be trying to send with
this conference uh with his words the
press conference he said quote at the
last meeting the last meeting when a Fed
chair Powell came out he said the FED
needs to see substantially more evidence
that inflation is on a sustained
downward path Market kind of took that
said okay well you know we're moving he
repeated that again today said we need
to see quote substantially more evidence
that was very early in the press
conference that inflation is coming back
down in order to stop what we're doing
which is stop raising rates uh the exact
words were while recent developments are
encouraging we will need substantially
more evidence to be confident that
inflation is on a sustained downward
path very very clear right saying look
we don't see that inflation You know
despite the fact fact that inflation is
coming down we see some progress we need
to see substantially more not a little
more not some more substantially more
being very clear on that he also noted I
think this might have been something
that financial markets got excited about
he said Financial conditions have
tightened considerably over the past
year and that's that's definitely true
Financial conditions have gotten a lot
tighter but over the past few months you
have seen stock prices rising you've
seen those bond yields going up pretty
significantly and sorry those bond
yields coming down as those bond prices
have gone up and that has been easing
Financial conditions and a number of
different indicators of financial Market
tightness have shown a precipitous
decline in the tightness of financial
markets I threw a couple of those out on
Twitter I don't want to get too nerdy
here on Market takes I know we got some
cool viewers out there who don't like to
nerd it up all that much but that's what
we've been seeing from financial markets
a a tightening but a loosening a
considerable loosening a bit over the
past few months so definitely at least
something that you want to keep an eye
on and that it's something to keep in
the back your mind in terms of what the
FED is doing what they're saying and
what they say they're doing and how
we're seeing the markets react to that
because the FED really enacts its
policies by raising rates that's one
thing but Financial guidance in terms of
what they say what they come out and say
they're going to do what they forecast
that's another big piece of how they
move financial markets and how they
accomplish their goals of monetary
policy and it doesn't appear that that
is working the way it typically has so
definitely something to keep your eye on
on December we saw the projections for
the Fed rate hikes in 2023 But Rising to
about 5.1 to 5.4 percent that would
imply a rate of between 5.0 and 5.25 or
5.25 to 5.5 Fed chair Powell only said
somewhere between five and five and a
quarter at this press conference which
means again he's kind of lowering back
from the fed's last summary of economic
projections that might have been what
got markets excited Venture pal I don't
know if you misspoke or just you know
wasn't thinking about things the way he
had talked about them before but he did
specifically say five to five point two
five it's a small difference but it is a
difference that is Meaningful uh as we
look out at the the chart or as we look
out at the rate of rate hikes so far and
the rate of rate hikes going forward
into the future they project they're
going to raise rates at least one more
time uh and and markets are saying look
we don't think that's going to happen
now as you see here on your screen
you're seeing the way that rates have
moved over the past year or so we saw
that first straight hike coming up in
March and then you see those consistent
rate hikes every month since then and
then you see that last hike up there uh
that we just got for this January
February meeting from the fed the FED
has continuing to raise rates and they
say that they're going to keep on that
path even though they've slowed down so
you see those numbers Rising a lot more
in some of those earlier months when we
had those 75 basis point rate hikes and
now we're down to 20 E5 basis points so
just wanted to throw that chart up there
to illustrate the kind of pace of Fed
rate increases that we have seen
consistently from the thread and the way
that has slowed down over the past few
months so listen as we're talking about
the environment coming into this meeting
it was bullish but worried and what
we've seen since this meeting is just
the bullishness no more of the worry we
saw the NASDAQ up huge we've seen risk
assets up huge uh getting a big Boost
from what the FED chairman said as well
as what we saw from the statement uh now
some things to keep in mind on the data
front as we're talking about the
environment the Jules report the job
openings and layover turnover the job
openings and layoffs survey labor
turnover survey excuse me job openings
and labor turnover survey that showed 11
million job openings in December showing
that the demand for labor is not slowing
down the Federal Reserve has pointed to
that specifically as a big measure and
something they need to see come down
well it went up it did exactly the
opposite of what they've said they want
to do the economic cost index however
over on the other hand showed smaller
than expected increases in wages so what
we are seeing wage increases are not
going up as quickly as they were they're
slowing down so people aren't making as
much more money but within that there's
a little bit of difference people who
are changing jobs still getting big
raises people who are staying at the
same jobs not getting as much but what
we are seeing is a Slowdown in terms of
hiring a lot of folks just kind of given
up saying you know we can't hire as many
people as we want to fine we'll just
stick it out where we are while there's
still expectations for and desire for
workers businesses aren't hiring as many
workers and those wages aren't Rising as
fast overall now some other data that
was not so great we have seen a strong
turn down in labor retail sales down two
months in a row for the first time since
late 2020. small business optimism down
11 months straight existing home sales
fell to the lowest since October 2010.
PMI reports from the ism s p all showing
the lowest since 2020. fed Regional
indexes hit getting the lowest since May
2020 that's uh the Richmond fed the
Empire State fed some of these Philly
fed the other indexes of manufacturing
activity around the country are slowing
down and hitting the lowest they have
been since we were in lockdown back in
2020. latest nabe business conditions
report wages Rose the majority of
respondents firms in the last three
months and more firms added workers than
reduced headcount but far more firms
than the past three years reported
falling profit margins all those things
tell you businesses are having a hard
time businesses are struggling however
the big piece of this inflation has
continued to decline so I want to first
throw up a chart here showing the CPI
Consumer Price Index now as you see on
your screen there you saw inflation kind
of starting to pick up there in 2020 and
then you see that big pickup going into
2022 but in the back half you see that
sustained Decline and that's I want to
throw it up just to illustrate the
increases and then decreases in
inflation or the disinflation that Fed
chair Powell talked about um that we
have seen since June it peaked up in
June at nine percent and we have seen
consistent disinflation not deflation
but disinflation costs increases coming
down or rising at a slower Pace I want
to also throw up here the PPI producer
price index that's how much businesses
have been paying for the materials that
they get and the increase that they've
seen since 2020. so again you see the
same thing but those prices are coming
down even faster and those price
increases are even lower on the PPI so
there is an expectation that as we see
Illustrated here in the CPI and in the
PPI that we see the prices that
businesses are paying the prices that
consumers are paying those are all
coming down there's an expectation that
the FED is going to be able to stop what
it's doing stop raising rates which
chokes off economic growth and that
that's going to push the stock market
higher and Traders are trying to get out
in front of that so let's let's talk
really quickly I just want to jump right
now into the market reaction because the
market reaction that we saw was very
unexpected at least was unexpected by me
from what I heard from the chairman and
what we really saw across the board was
an increase in Risk assets a flight to
risk and and big pickups in some of the
most risky areas of the market so what
I'm talking about is the NASDAQ up two
percent it was up as much as two and a
half percent uh during the the speech by
Fed chair Powell the s p up just one
percent we know NASDAQ is the home of
those risky stocks those high-flying
tech stocks that have taken a lot of
risk you also saw when you look over at
crypto Bitcoin up three percent ethereum
up four percent Litecoin up five percent
as you move out the risk scale on even
some of these cryptocurrencies you're
seeing a bigger response and a higher
increase in some of those uh and some of
those assets when we look at the bond
market which I like to call the real
Market we saw just a really falling off
a cliff of some of these bond yields
across the board you see right now the
30-year bond is down by about 10 basis
points the 10-year note which is the
most traded down by about 11 basis
points even going down to the two-year
note which is the most sensitive to Fed
rate hikes that's down 16 basis points
from where it was to start the day that
tells you that investors think the FED
is going to slow down they're going to
stop raising rates and maybe even
reverse course turnaround start cutting
rates that's what we're seeing in the
market across the board and when you
look out at the dollar the US dollar
versus other currencies the dollar is
moving downward at a sustained Pace the
euro is up over one percent against the
dollar today the U.S dollar Index down
by about one percent and it really has
been on a significant downward path
since about November we were up in terms
of the dollar Index at about 110. uh
we're down all the way near about 100
right now 101.15 as we speak right now
on the dollar Index so that tells you
about what folks are expecting affecting
the fed the FED to slow down stop maybe
even turn to rate Cuts as we talked
about in the FED fund Futures video that
we've got up here on my YouTube channel
so check that out if you've got the time
if you haven't minute we talked about
what that was and why it's happening why
investors really don't believe the FED
another thing to really keep your eye on
I talked about this we did another a
project here at the Wall Street Journal
about super core inflation Fed chair
Jerome Palace talked about core Services
minus housing that's been a big focus of
theirs because as the pace of overall
inflation has just come down it's hard
for them to justify well we got to keep
raising rates fed share pal pointed to
core Services excluding housing
basically that's the super core super
core is a much cooler name much funner
to say than core Services excluding
housing we'd explain what that is we're
going to link to that in the description
of the video uh when that's out here as
soon as we finish right here on Market
Tech so check that out as well uh listen
as we move on to the outlook for 2023
the Fed so far is still sticking with
its Target of 5.1 to 5.4 percent which
is in the summary of economic
projections but fed share pal today said
five to five and a quarter that's a
little bit lower got the market thinking
okay maybe the FED is ready to accept
that the job is done and it can you know
wash its hands of all these rate hikes
doesn't need to continue putting
pressure on the economy and that's going
to help bring down the price of mortgage
rates it's going to help bring down
small business loans going to help bring
down credit card interest rates that
could get people spending again that
could be good for the economy gotten
markets bullish as we look out there the
market reaction tells us that investors
are watching the fed's deeds and not its
words remember we were at 75 basis
points just a few Mo a few months ago
the Fed was Raising 75 basis points then
they slowed it down to 15. now they've
slowed it down to 25 and the market is
saying we think you're almost done we
don't care what you say and your
conviction in this press conference was
not enough for us to revert on our
expectations and the bets that we've
made that's what you're seeing also one
thing to watch out for our very own Nick
timaros here at the Wall Street Journal
reported and we know he's the FED
Whisperer when the FED talks they talk
to Nick timaros and he talks to y'all
he's saying that there are some
differing opinions showing up up on the
fomc the board that makes the decisions
about rate hikes or rate cuts and that
some of the new fed members if you look
at that the latest fed statement you see
some new names out there Esther George
long time Hawk gone out of there you're
seeing some new names of some folks who
are much more dovish as in much more
worried about the economy thinking that
we need to keep rates low than they are
worried about inflation and that could
be another reason why we start to see
less red less rate hikes less the feds
stomping on the break and slowing down
slowing their role and doing less and
more room for the economy to grow more
room for stocks to really take off
that's why I think you're seeing these
big moves in the stock market now that
could reverse course it would not
surprise me to see reversal of this as
some folks go back and they look at what
the chairman said and they say oh no
he's not going to do that but we shall
see for right now risk is all the rage
and that's what's going on listen what
comes next because you know we're always
looking forward never looking backwards
even though we got backwards looking
data the Challenger job Cuts report that
is not been a thing that investors have
been paying a lot of attention to in the
market I think that's a mistake
Challenger job cut Report with so much
emphasis on the labor market in terms of
whether we're going to have a recession
or whether inflation is going to keep
Rising wages are a big part of that
you're going to want to look at that
Challenger job Cuts report out tomorrow
check that out for sure of course then
we've got the jobs report that's the big
one we had the ADP jobs increase our
jobs estimate today that showed about a
hundred eight thousand jobs added much
less than expected that was good news as
seen by the market and we'll see we get
the government's jobs report that's out
Friday that's obviously one that can't
be missed and then another one a little
bit more on the fringes the employment
trends index that's gonna be it on
Monday you've also got and you know I
don't like to talk politics here because
that's that's for the birds but
President Biden will announce his fiscal
2024 uh budget that could have big
implications because as the FED is
raising rates as the economy is
tightening up as businesses are having
all this trouble if with a new
Republican House of Representative the
president comes out and puts forward an
austere budget a budget that puts
forward Some Cuts that maybe doesn't
raise spending that cuts down spending
that could be a sign for markets that
there's something to worry about and
maybe the recession could settle so
you're going to want to watch that
President Biden budget that's supposed
to come out here on Monday keep your eye
on that that has big implications for
the inflation expectations and recession
expectations listen and then Market
takes we will be back with you on
February 15th we're not going to be
doing anything we got we got some some
heat coming for you on the overall
YouTube channel but no Market takes
until February 15th and we'll be right
back here breaking it down listen I am
Dion Robert Bowen I know you could have
been anywhere in the world but you're
here with me and I want to say I thank
you for that catch us back here uh
February 15th on Market takes that's
going to do it I hope to see you then